david why do you think christian
prophets
are on the rise again this is a really
interesting question and there's a super
compelling article in the new york times
about christian prophets
and their predictions and one of the
points that the article makes
is that right now there is a real
hunger for reassurance and clarity
uh in many areas of american
culture in particular we have seen
donald trump be the least popular
president by approval rating in the
polling era
leave the white house with the lowest
approval rating
of any president in the polling era with
so many
failed promises from donald trump and
for the left who never believed any of
that stuff to begin with
and on average is less religious than
the right and to the extent that the
left is religious
it tends to be less the sort of
charismatic evangelical christianity
that is so much more prominent on the
right in the united states
the left isn't really looking for
prophecy
for reassurance and clarity because much
of the left never believed trump to
begin with
and much of the left doesn't look to uh
these sort of
um televangelist equivalents
for guidance on the right you saw
an initially resistant evangelical
christian wing of uh america resist
trump at the beginning sort of get
behind ted cruz and some other
candidates in the 2016 republican
primary
eventually trump won and they certainly
weren't going to vote for hillary
clinton so you saw a lot of these folks
who would not normally go
for the multiple times divorced guy who
pays off
uh uh porn stars and whatever else okay
they went with him and then everything
he promised he didn't do
now some of them just continued to
insist he did all of it
he was the most pro-life president and
all of this different stuff
um but many of them now are seeking some
kind of reassurance and clarity after
seeing trump not do any of the stuff he
promised to do
and then lose to joe biden who despite
actually being more devoutly religious
than donald trump
is catholic and is a democrat which does
not go too well
for a lot of these charismatic and
evangelical christian communities so
there's a big demand for someone who
will tell you
in clear terms here's what's going to
happen and that is part of the reason
why christian prophets are
are sort of seeing this resuscitation
the newly popular once again
widely making wrong predictions as has
always been the case now interestingly
astrology is also expanding in
popularity
and the number of americans who believe
in psychics
are also expanding and i think that this
is just a
general sort of reaction to
uncertain political times combined with
a global hundred year pandemic
and the desire to have someone who will
tell you here's how things are going to
be
in your life in the political future of
the united states
etc we know that at minimum
one third of americans say that they're
suffering from stress and anxiety
as a result of the pandemic when we ask
when will it be over we don't really
know we're starting to get more clarity
at least on the trajectory
over the next few months and things are
looking better and hopefully it'll keep
going that way but for a year now we've
had such uncertainty
that it is natural that people would
want answers and they would want someone
who will tell you definitively
who is more arrogant in their
predictions
than these particular televangelist
type christian prophets whose income and
livelihood depends on
even if they don't know what the hell is
going to happen telling you that they
definitely do
and because of that i'm not particularly
surprised
that this world of christian punditry
and prophecy has surged in popularity if
i'm missing something in that analysis
let me know i'm curious to hear from you
we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today make sure you get instant
access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com we will see you then